yeah i remember like the only what they
called the
audio
i'm like audio illusion audio illusion
that's the yeah it's actually it's not
really an audio illusion it's just did
you ever did you guys ever do like the
uh frequency test where you have to like
test your frequency
and um
like i remember i was fancy my i
remember my frequency was like so
[ __ ] good as a kid and i thought i'm
never going to lose this
i don't know like dude as a kid do you
ever did you ever get that point where
i grown up told you that this is going
to happen to you when you grow up yeah
and as a kid you're just like that's
never going to happen to me it's never
going to [ __ ] happen
i remember the first time i felt old was
the first time i did the second time i
did did a frequency test when i was like
mid-20s and i'm just like
this isn't the same number as i remember
as a kid
the grown-ups are right i'm getting old
wait wait so is the frequency test like
the how much you can hear is that the
one yeah so like the better your hearing
is the higher the frequency
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah generally when
you get around to 30 it starts to get a
lot worse yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
doesn't like who the [ __ ] needs to hear
like the
high killer i mean i i immediately felt
that like because you know in like some
arcades in japan no yeah i like the keto
tone that like stops like uh animals
from coming into oh yeah yeah and uh
every time we walk past like an arcade
with like a bunch of friends that'd be
like oh [ __ ] i'll be like what
i legitimately don't it's that it's
actually an advantage here yeah right
yeah because sydney sydney can hear it
and i can't anymore yeah right yeah
yeah
apparently apparently it hurts i'm just
like
apparently like in a lot of shops in
japan they just played us like
i can't describe it i think isn't it you
can like teenagers those will stop
teenagers from like
people from loitering
i've also heard it's to stop birds from
flying cats and cats okay can you hear a
connor yeah i can hear it okay what does
it sound like i was gonna describe what
it was and i realized
i just realized i've never heard of an
uncomfortable ring in your ears
it's not it doesn't particularly feel
good it kind of hurts
i don't know it just hurts
it looks like that's what that's what's
designed to do
what i don't understand is is that if
they've just put this high frequency
alarm or ring to stop
birds mosquitoes animals and loitering
oh okay
i don't know which one it's actually for
might be is it for humans or animals i
don't know apparently it's for both
because youths can hear it as well
probably should have picked a lower
frequency though because it doesn't work
if you've just got [ __ ] hearing then you
just immune to it like
it's really just stopped like kids
okay
oh okay okay that's uh that's like i've
never been able to hear it though even
even when i was a kid yeah but you've
been listening to like music for like
yeah
yeah i've been so many concerts where my
ears just got [ __ ] you're gonna be
like 14 what why are you saying to me
god i'm still like that yeah yeah true
you are your hearing is really bad yeah
no but i talked about on the podcast
remember i was like because when we went
to go do the health checkup and i got an
a for my hearing and then i realized oh
i don't have bad hearing i just don't
listen you're just [ __ ] dumb yeah i
just i just don't care about what you're
saying sometimes but i just shut it out
true true that's what it is